so did all your summer plans get
cancelled last minute and now you are
lying on your bed bored out of your mind
the next school year is coming but you
still haven't accomplished much yet well
i got you we're gonna make this
somewhere the most fun beautiful and
productive summer ever hi i'm shalot
fraser a second year computational
neuroscience phd student and today i
want to give you three topics or three
ideas areas that you can use to make
your summer a little bit more productive
a fun and or learn reset yourself so
we're gonna dive straight into it so the
three topics i want to talk about today
is one for your resume so how to get
certain ideas or topics for that you can
put on your resume after you finish this
summer the second one is for learning i
myself find curiosity and wisdom two of
the most important topics and i think
the summer is such a good time to really
explore these and three is building
habits and a healthier mindset i think
throughout the year it's kind of hard
sometimes to focus on healthy habits and
or a healthy mindset and i think the
summer is a really good time to reset
yourself so let's get into the first
topic so the first topic i want to talk
about is for your resume so i want to
give you a list of six ideas that you
can use to upgrade or spice up your
resume a little bit i think the summer
especially if you're a student is
usually around two to three months and
that's just a really good period to
upgrade your resume a little bit and if
you haven't applied for an internship
and you're now really regretting that i
still think you can do a lot of work and
or projects to make your resume stand
out amongst the crowd so the first thing
i want to say is to show your work and
this is kind of from this book austin
cleon and he really actually inspired me
to make a youtube channel because the
idea from show your work is that your
work doesn't really exist unless it's
somewhere out there on the internet or
in real life and i think a lot of us
actually have a lot of skills and or
ideas but we never really put them out
there and even if people are not really
watching you or looking at what you're
doing i still think it's good if you
have a small hub on the internet to show
your work and show what you're actually
doing and are passionate about so the
first thing i would recommend to you is
to for example start a youtube channel
of course this may sound crazy if you
never considered it but if you even in
the slightest have considered to start a
youtube channel and or tick tock i would
highly recommend it i think it has
taught me so much from video editing
storytelling and also just getting over
the fear of people judging you or having
an opinion about you on the internet and
a second thing you can think of is for
example to start a project on kaggle so
i think it's really good if you want to
upgrade your coding skills for example
during the summer to look at these kind
of projects from kaggle so on kaggle is
this website where you can join a
competition or look at certain coding
projects and these projects you can then
put on your github for example if you've
completed one and they are quite time
intensive so myself i have been telling
myself to finish a kaggle competition
for ages now but just because it takes
so much time to really accomplish
something in this field or on a
competition like this i haven't been
able to but i am planning for the next
year to finally put my feet down and try
to really finish a gaggle competition if
you're by the way interested or maybe
wanting to do this together or something
like that i am thinking of perhaps
starting like a study group so if you're
interested in something like that put it
down in the comments below and perhaps
at a certain point i will start a study
group or on youtube or on zoom just to
see if we can motivate and inspire each
other so the third thing you can
consider is to start a website and or
blog blog posts so i personally really
love reading blog posts and i think it's
a really good way to establish a writing
practice and also to increase your
writing skills so starting a website is
actually really easy nowadays you have
websites like squarespace or ghost that
i'm sure most of you have heard of so
for about eight euros i think per month
this is not sponsored by the way but you
can get a square space platform and then
you can start your website and i think
especially if you're in your undergrad
or during your graduate degree you learn
a lot of topics and or skills that you
will probably later forget and it's kind
of nice if during this time you can
already start the habit of writing down
little blog posts on the things you have
learned and you never really know when
you put your work on the internet what
will come out of it it could be that
someone reads your blog post and is
really inspires and inspired and then
reaches out to you and maybe you can get
another opportunity or a friend or
something like that so i think having
your work somewhere on the internet is
really important on number four you can
start a tutorial on medium so if you're
a programmer you probably know websites
like medium and these are usually
websites where people put a little
article or an explanation or tutorial on
a skill or thing they have learned and i
personally use medium a lot when i'm
programming and i think if you're also
programming or have another skill it's
kind of good to put the things you learn
on a website like medium and perhaps
help someone else develop their skills
or bring them give them a leg up and i
think when you're considering on what to
put on the internet it's good to think
about things that you use the most so if
for example you're an avid twitter user
it's kind of good to also start sending
out tweets just to contribute to the
conversation and to the platforms that
you really like using on number five a
really good website that i like is
fiverr or upwork and this is more if you
want to for example do some teaching or
you have a certain skill that you want
to share and the thing i like about
fiverr is that you can kind of put
yourself on there as a freelancer and
for example if you're a student in a
certain field you can consider teaching
high school students on fiverr or if you
have some data coding skills you can
also put these skills on there and
people will hire you and i know some
friends of mine have made quite a lot of
money on a website as fifer and that is
kind of nice during the summer if you
can just get some extra cash and on
number six and maybe this is already a
little bit too late but is to
reach out to certain professors to ask
them if they have an internship position
during a period that i had between my
two master's degrees i had this six
month period where i wasn't really doing
anything and at that time i decided to
reach out to a professor i knew in
berlin and asked him if he had a
position and he actually told me he
could get a small funding scheme for me
and so i could go to berlin for six
months without really having to pay
anything and i learned a lot during that
time and this just came out of me
sending one small email and of course i
have to tell you to be respectful when
you approach these professors and be
really sincere in your interest because
if you're not super involved in the
research they do or super interested
they usually don't reply back but in
general it is kind of good to reach out
to a few professors and maybe one of
them will reply back and you can get a
really cool internship then the second
topic that i kind of want to dive into
is to learn new skills during summer so
i think summer is the perfect period to
set up learning a new skill for the new
year so for example if during the new
years you have thought of i would love
to learn this skill it is kind of hard
usually during the year to make time for
learning this new skill and i think
especially the first few weeks of
learning a new skill are really
important because usually if you already
get if you already get the momentum it's
kind of easy to continue learning a
skill but if you have to start from
scratch it is kind of good to put in
some intensive work at the beginning so
there are different kind of things that
you can consider to learn a new skill of
course the most obvious one is to do
moocs online or these online tutorials
slash courses and i will get a list of
three that i really like so i really
like this course on coursera called
machine learning by andrei
i i never know how to pronounce his last
name but it's one of the most popular
courses on machine learning right now
annie ethan has provided this machine
learning specialization i will put the
link down below and another course that
i've talked about before but that i
really like if you're interested in
programming or want to get into it it's
called 100 days of code and it's really
teaches you everything about python and
how to set up different coding projects
and how to make projects and the coolest
thing i think about it is in the last 10
days of this course you will learn how
to set up your own projects that you can
even put on github for example and then
on that related note i also really like
data camp i've heard from a lot of
friends that are a little bit more
beginners that data camp is a really
easy and friendly way to learn coding i
think if you already know a little bit
of coding it's maybe a little bit too
easy but i do think it's good if you're
a beginner to get into the coding
workflow another thing that you can
consider during summer is to join a
summer school so for example i just
finished a summer school in nermatch i
was a ta there and i thought it was one
of the most brilliant summer schools
i've ever been to
so or ever taught at so if you're
thinking of doing a summer school i
would highly recommend this one it's in
computational neuroscience and they
teach you about computational
neuroscience and everything related to
the field in three weeks and it i do
have to say it's super intense and what
i've heard from the students they really
enjoyed it but it was really hard at the
beginning but i do think joining a
summer school like this or another topic
that you're interested in is a really
nice way to meet people that are
interested in the same field as you and
also to learn a lot about a topic that
is not at university because i think at
university a lot of times because we get
grades this can be really demotivating
whereas in a summer school you really
learn about a topic in this like free
spirited way where just the focus is on
learning and not on getting grades or
beating your peers and for me at least
that's really refreshing and a really
nice way to learn about a new topic
without the pressure of university and
the third thing i would consider to
learn a language so if you're thinking
about studying a language i think that's
a really good idea so i myself have
learned a lot of languages in the past
in the different countries that i lived
in and i think that usually when i
started learning a language i usually
started it during summer because in
summer it's just like such a good time
to really immerse yourself in language
so you can consider moving to that
country for a little bit or traveling in
that country for a little bit but even
if you don't have that money or time
there are amazing websites such as
italki or linguda that allow you to
speak with native speakers through zoom
for example without having to travel
there i myself am now considering to
restart learning french a little bit i
used to be really good at it but i
haven't spoken french for five years i
think but i think summer is a really
good time to restart this habit and kind
of kick start my learning journey if
you're considering of learning a
language i would love to hear what kind
of language you're considering of
learning or which languages you speak i
always am very interested in fellow
linguists so put it down in the comments
below and the last topic i want to talk
about is building better and cleaner
habits so i think throughout the year we
can kind of let go of ourselves a little
bit and there are certain habits at
least for me that really slip through
and that i usually forget thinking about
and these are habits such as eating good
food and cooking a really good meal or i
have it such as exercising and i think
retraining your habits during summer is
a really nice period because you can
really consider like why did i let go of
these habits throughout the year because
you really have the time during summer
to kind of focus on certain habits and
if they don't work for you to kind of
consider why is this habit not working
for me and what do i have to change in
my environment or in my psyche to kind
of retrain or reintroduce this habit so
four habits that i would consider
working on if um that i usually also
work on during my summers are reading
books i love reading books and i read
books a lot but sometimes i do have to
say during stressful exam periods or
when i have to work a lot it is a habit
that sometimes slips through and usually
when i'm in summer i really try to
rethink my environment such that i can
optimize reading books so for example i
put my kindle next to my bed again or
buy a few known books that i want to
read for the new year and also i update
my goodreads such that all the books
that i want to read are in there and all
the books that i've read throughout the
year are kind of in there as well so one
book that i'm reading right now is atlas
of the heart by brene brown and it's an
amazing book if you're considering a
summer read i would highly recommend it
it teaches you all about emotions and
the language of emotion and how we can
speak better about our emotions and
communicate it better to friends and
family another habit i am working on
right now on the summer is just going
outside more i personally love being
outside but i'm also very much a
homebody so i also love being inside but
things i try to do during summer that i
usually do indoors are for example
swimming i usually go swimming with my
sister a lot but during summer it's
actually kind of nice to go swimming
outside and not in a swimming pool
another one is hiking i really like
walking and going outside but
rediscovering hiking routes usually
takes a lot of time and i think summer
is perfect for that because then i can
just invite a few friends and we walk
around the neighborhood and see if there
are a few new areas or routes that we
can consider walking on another habit
that i usually really cultivate during
summer are these habits of mindfulness
or joy and peace and i think a few
things that i really do try to do more
mindful during summer is creating
beautiful meals for example so usually
when i cook i tend to just
eat what's in the fridge as fast as
possible but during summer you have a
little bit more time and it's for
example really nice to go to the market
and pick out some really nice fruits or
to have a little discussion at the
farmer's market which is the best
produce and where you can buy it and i
think these kind of habits really do
spark joy and sometimes it's a bit hard
to make time for them and the last type
of habits that i always work on during
summer is exercise and with exercise i
don't really mean making a new routine
but usually i try to discover new sports
or exercise that i really love so right
now i'm doing like kind of like become
yoga or hot yoga and it's just a
different type of yoga that i've never
considered before because i usually
always do ashtanga and it's just a
little bit different and during summers
you just have a little bit more time
mentally as well to explore new
possibilities so if there's a certain
sports you've considered of trying i
think during the summers is a really
good period because usually are also
discounts at certain schools and you can
just try it and you can also invite some
of your friends that maybe throughout
the year they kind of are busy or they
have to work a lot in summers usually
most of us have a little bit more time
so you can explore these new exercise
regimes together so these were my tips
for having an optimal summer but the
most important of course is that you
have as much as fun and enjoyment as
possible and really try to meet your
friends and family if you have any crazy
summer plans for this year i would love
to hear them so put them down in the
comments below and otherwise see you
next week bye